[Musik]
palmen und sonnenschein den alltag
vergessen ferienzeit ist angesagt
willkommen in fort lauderdale florida
[Musik]
eine reisegruppe aus dem aargau ist
unterwegs zum hafen ihr ziel die allure
of the seas das größte kreuzfahrtschiff
der welt
[Musik]
fünf ehemalige schüler geboren 1947 aus
bremgarten mit ihren partnerinnen die
gemeinsame jugend verbindet sie und eine
enge freundschaft
es ist ein jahrgangstreffen der
besonderen art eine traumreise durch die
karibik auf einem schiff der superlative
auch nicht muss her
mülltonnen an
[Musik]
ich bin
wahrscheinlich froh enthält die breite
und
[Musik]
dann geht es hinein
hohes freddy guido und die anderen
können kaum fassen dass dies ein schiff
ist
die plan cius im hafen von longyearbyen
spitzbergen
das schiff ist speziell für
polarregionen ausgerüstet an bord ist
auch meeresbiologe michael wenger als
reiseleiter gehört er zur besatzung
[Musik]
home sweet home
rund 20 wochen im jahr verbringt er hier
viel zeit die kollegen zu begrüßen hat
er nicht die 41 jährige muss sich auf
die expeditionsfahrt vorbereiten
[Musik]
katakombe wer die nyt für passagiere
alles nur für das darf man die ganze
richtige sache für das darf ja t shirt
zusätzliche gummistiefel
alles so ein material halt notwendig
werden experte expeditionsleiter und
jetzt muss ich wieder kraxeln
schule sein exil
zweitwichtigsten radio
mit denen dinge und überall nur so zeigt
es hier weder
v
wir haben wir gesagt
[Musik]
us und die anderen wollen auf den beginn
der reise anstoßen doch wo befindet sich
eine bar auf diesem riesigen kann 18
decks hoch ist er
362 meter lang und bietet platz für bis
zu 8500 menschen eine schwimmende
kleinstadt
ja
nein
unten im schiff wird derweil unter
hochdruck geladen 1200 paletten mit
lebensmitteln müssen innerhalb weniger
stunden an ihrem platz sein
stress pur auch für so chef tobias
frieden burka ist der stellvertreter des
chefkochs und seit einem jahr auf dem
kreuzfahrtschiff im einsatz
wie jede woche muss er am abfahrtstag
qualität und menge der ware
kontrollieren
unter anderem verbrauchen wir annahmen
nur an lammkarree also an den rippen
stück
8000 kilo
wir haben wir 11.000 stück ananas ja die
sind aus costa rica weil in amerika
wachsen halt keine ananas oder nicht
diese spezielle sorte die wahrheit
benutzen ja dann haben wir hier halt die
ganzen frischen orangen und grapefruit
helle kernlosen trauben und das ist halt
ich sag mal auch noch was ganz
besonderes verbrauchen durchschnittlich
650 kilo erdbeeren in der woche ja
es hat schon etwas andere hausnummer als
als in einem hotel
[Musik]
die aargauer erkunden die außen decks
stehen
[Musik]
die macher haben dann auch nicht gut
erinnerungsfotos für zu hause
[Musik]
eine woche wird die gruppe auf dem
ozeanriesen verbringen
[Applaus]
die pflanz muss liegt inzwischen vor
anker
[Musik]
an land hilft reiseleiter michael die
letzten vorräte verladen nichts darf
fehlen denn während 13 tagen wird das
schiff nun fern jeglicher zivilisation
unterwegs sein
ausweis
hallo zusammen ich warte schon auf die
dose sie sind jetzt richtig leid und
richtig gestimmt für die nächsten tag
und dafür der stiko die abfahrt mache
wenn durch die akku vergönnt das
wichtigste
recht okay mit kamera ok wenn du den so
die absicht ich bitte da chris klang
umfassen und handgelenk und aber laufen
107 passagiere kommen an bord darunter
rund 40 schweizer
adrian und meier nussbaumer sind voller
vorfreude auf ihr ferienabenteuer
[Musik]
das ehepaar aus gründungs gönnt sich
jedes jahr eine exklusive reise mit der
plan cius begeben sie sich nun auf eine
expeditionskreuzfahrten von spitzbergen
nach grönland
[Musik]
maria arbeitet als prokurist in
adrian ist schreiner mit eigenem betrieb
in zürich
für die kabine auf dem obersten deck
musste das kinderlose paar tief in die
tasche greifen rund 11.000 franken pro
person
entsprechend hoch sind nun ihre
erwartungen
[Gelächter]
richtig
gesehen und fast dahin nicht leicht
die kabine ist auch in der karibik thema
sie ist um einiges billiger als die auf
dem expeditionsschiff
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kirchmaier und astrid linie sind erst
seit vier jahren ein paar es ist
passiert astrid leutert ein
personalrestaurant die kreuzfahrt in die
karibik ist ihre erste gemeinsame
fernreise und astrids weiteste reise
überhaupt
so
nebenan freddy tellenbach und guido
fischer
und
das musik wird wenn man das tanz musik
machen
und
glauben wir nicht die in rom machte
zwischen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
pünktlich setzt sich der ozeanriese in
bewegung routine für die crew ein erster
höhepunkt für uns und seine kollegen
alle mädels
[Musik]
6000 passagiere auf einer luxus reise in
die karibik mit der allure of the seas
der verlockung der meere
die kreuzfahrt beginnt in fort
lauderdale über nassau auf den bahamas
geht die reise zu den jungferninseln
danach sind marken und wieder zurück
nach florida
[Musik]
los geht es auch auf der norwegischen
insel spitzbergen
von longyearbyen fährt die pflanze aus
richtung norden nach einem landgang auf
der insel utoya geht es durch die
grönländische see nach ito chor mit in
grönland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so gut wie heute ging es astrid und os
nicht immer
beide haben vor einigen jahren ihre
ehepartner verloren und sich gefunden
davon erfasst
si
da bin ich mir so leicht wegkommen und
sachlich
miteinander
spielen und
im
finale gestanden und so hätte hitlers
armeen
anzusehen
ich bin froh einander finden und ich
kann damit erhält man so sagen ich bin
ein spontaner typ und beschlossen
spontan das für mich sehr wichtig
[Musik]
die schöne ambiente
treibeis vor spitzbergen
[Musik]
während die pflanze aus richtung norden
fährt wird im speisesaal das frühstück
serviert
gesprächsthema nummer eins am tisch ist
natürlich das eis
für maja und adrian ist es ein
vorgeschmack auf das was noch kommen
soll
und ich sage ich mal sieht meierhans
netzstörung mehrere
jubiläumsjahr 20 jährige jubiläum 20
jahre
später geworden und ich bin leider
ausgefallen und heimliche gründermesse
36 uhr über das gemeinsame
den jubiläen und
kreisklasse
2 ticks höher ist reiseleiter michael
bereits bei der arbeit eher aktualisiert
einen vortrag über tiere in der arktis
relativ autark ist es ziemlich hektisch
die polizei tun und das andere den
halter harmonika
müssen alles experte in unserem fall und
höchster schafft blieb nicht stehen
sondern davon wenn immer neue sachen
neue erkenntnis
und dass er gern wieder für mittlerweile
haben sie mir in erster linie
alltag in der karibik zeit für die
aargauer den pool bereich zu erkunden
kg
dann aber auf hintere
übernommen
[Musik]
einen optimalen platz zu finden der alle
beglückt ist gar nicht so einfach
[Musik]
zu groß ist das angebot
absolut
ich bin
aber ich denke schon
es dreht sieht das anders
davon
aber ich werde erst
der zweite küchenchef macht wie jeden
morgen seinen rundgang
sodass er setzt auch 1 von meinauto.de
kaffee pro monat hier gibt es ein
kleines frühstück für die gäste
und wir haben natürlich einfach auch ein
backoffice
good morning
aber vom frühstück ist schon alles so
weit weg dass gut da bleibt nicht viel
übrig
damit zwei bleche kurs übrig fast
zweieinhalb fläche so und das ist eine
überproduktion und das sollte eigentlich
nicht vorkommen beruflich hat es der
32-jährige bereits weit gebracht er ist
für acht der 24 restaurants
verantwortlich so sorento es ist auch
noch zu
silber am herd steht er dabei kaum noch
so jetzt weil es so anders ist es halt
so ich habe hier meine city mein chef de
partie st
germain wer gerade etwas ungeschickt ist
mein job
rallye
während im einen restaurant schon bald
das mittagessen serviert wird gibt es im
anderen noch frühstück
[Musik]
das zum beispiel gefällt mir überhaupt
nicht es sind einfach zu viele
übereinander das ist halt faulheit ja
weil damit halt einfach viel aufgetischt
damit man halt weniger austauschen
alle schüler
es liegt viel gepäck aufeinander nächste
woche kommen die obersten chefs das ist
nicht akzeptabel
vom stress in der küche merkt man bei
den passagieren nichts
sie entspannen im wohltemperierten
whirlpool hoch über dem meer
bis zum 11
das stimmt schon
gemacht und die typische amerikanische
oder künstlichkeit trotzdem bieten habe
ich angefangen
zurück in die arktis
[Musik]
maria und adrian sind ein eingespieltes
team ein halbes leben lang sind sie
bereits ein paar
[Musik]
der heißt schon von beginn an war reisen
immer ein fester bestandteil ihrer
beziehung
mit zwei halbjahren hariri klapptischen
bislang sehe ich für mich ausruhen gut
erfolg sie und
ist weil du so ist für mich nicht fremd
sie ich glaube das schafft
es geht ja sehr viel mit dir die familie
zum dollfuß die bliebe dann lebst du
daheim dass sie stellen ihre
welt
[Musik]
dass auch diese kreuzfahrt zu einem
unvergesslichen erlebnis wird daran
arbeitet die besatzung oben auf der
brücke
expeditionsleiterin delfin und
reiseleiter michael besprechen den
ersten landgang
man fährt das letzte schlauchboot zurück
das entscheiden wir an land wir sollten
den passagieren bei der ersten wanderung
genug zeit geben
[Musik]
und letscha b ich vertraue einen barcode
und hätte uns von der insel wo man durch
fand betrieb ist sozusagen
das gebiet stand 68 mal
handschuhe handschuhe tendenz hinter der
vorsätzlichen und heizstoffe liegt
natürlich immer die grüße spanien
[Musik]
michael darf nie ohne gewehr an land
eisbären sind gefährlich daher sind alle
guides bewaffnet
[Musik]
dieses abenteuer wollen sich die
aargauer nicht entgehen lassen die
slackline
margret traut sich als erster schon
früher habe sie immer zu den mutigen
gehört beteuert der mann emi
passau
das luftige vergnügen ist jedoch nicht
jedermanns sache
über die höhe jedoch nicht wenig weniger
[Gelächter]
erlaubt
[Musik]
auf der fläche ja auch mit englischer
leute
die tore
doppelt
die pflanze muss begann ihre fahrt
richtung grönland in libyen nun liegt
sie bei der insel hydrinos klar vor
anker
[Musik]
auf dem programm stehen heute
verschiedene wanderungen dafür werden
die passagiere in drei gruppen
aufgeteilt
reiseleiter michael begleitet die
sogenannten lang wanderer
drei stunden lang werden sie die insel
erkunden
eine weitere gruppe macht sich bereit
für die überfahrt
auch maria oder adrian sind mit dabei
sie machen nur eine kurze wanderung
[Musik]
das gelände ist schwierig wege gibt es
keine michael muss sowohl die passagiere
als auch die umgebung genau im auge war
[Musik]
das könnte gefährlich werden rund 3000
bären leben in spitzbergen
[Musik]
das ganze findet intel-center sich
extrem limacher wenn du liegst
vorsteht was unglaublich findet ihr wie
vor strebe nicht lange potenziell
verstoße das ist sonst um
permanente wollte
brand gerade regel im alter in dem man
dann je nach land bayerischer minister
wenn die relativ fitte backwerk
gruppen einfach zurück
machen
gestohlen es gewährt und sowieso nur
20km anspruch
für die passagiere sind eisbären
momentan jedoch kein thema sie genießen
die raue natur und die milden
temperaturen des arktischen spätsommers
maja und adrian haben nur einen
spaziergang gemacht der grund sind
marias rückenprobleme sie hat mehrere
versteifte wirbel und ist nicht mehr so
fit wie früher aber
dann habe ich so viel erlebt dass wir so
viel von dem werk das jetzt nicht den
bodenheimer langweilig
[Musik]
auch für michaels gruppe geht es
richtung schiff
[Musik]
hondo de
gut
jede blau toni bayerische gute platz
schon wieder eins zu eins er kann sich
über andere gifte über die
entsprechenden macht ruhig
auf dem großen schiff versammelt
chefkoch berg mcknight sein team zum
sogenannten tasting die kirche
präsentieren ihm dabei die verschiedenen
menüs für das abendessen
fantastisch achtet darauf dass die
teller später auch so gut aussehen und
jetzt lasst uns probieren
besonderes augenmerk legt der chefkoch
auf aussehen und geschmack außerdem
sollen die köche die arbeit der kollegen
kritisch unter die lupe nehmen
okay das war's
er ist ein typ sehr gut
lammkeule lecker und zahlt seit 8
manchmal sind 23 davon nicht ganz durch
die müssen dann nochmals in den ofen
aber die desserts sind exzellent alle
süß
heute habe ich zum ersten mal etwas
anderen auberginen zu bemängeln sie sind
leicht verkauft er frei als al dente
alles andere ist wunderbar schaut dass
beim servieren alles schön heiß ist und
nicht vergessen wir haben ein volles
schiff mit 6000 passagieren
[Musik]
im rot wurden im norden von spitzbergen
hat die besatzung doch noch einen
eisbären entdeckt kapitel über kopf
versucht das schiff in seine nähe zu
steuern
[Musik]
sicherheit
doch das letztlich aber
ja das ist natürlich schon nicht alle
tag und das ist faszination pur will die
sind zu selten und ja dass man sie in
freier natur sich eine
zulässig
wenn david schlitt für praktisch
begeistert
denn nimmt war das ist genau das was
zieht und sie wahrnehmen von fcs ist
sklavisch der hauptprobe und gut wenn es
trotzdem so nah wie möglich an
maschine faszination des schreckens
keine welt an land sieben bayern aber
alle warnt sie
frieden ist ein traum
dass ich wirklich
und sagt wir haben
aber das ist unser ding
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es ist ein besonderer abend auch für
astrid und
zweisamkeit vor dem nächsten höhepunkt
der reise
[Musik]
etwas später beginnt unten in die
kapitänskajüte
anlass für den sich die schweizer schick
gemacht haben
[Musik]
einmal dem kapitän höchstpersönlich die
hand schütteln dieser gelegenheit lässt
sich die reisegruppe aus bremgarten
nicht entgehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und diese spieler
helmut ja
[Musik]
man übt sich in smalltalk und zeigt sich
beeindruckt
[Musik]
in der küche überwacht koch tobias die
letzten vorbereitungen für das galadiner
alles ist bis ins kleinste
durchorganisiert
hier haben
sie haben wir die fische so genannte
fisherman's plate das ist halt der
hunger ja mit den garnelen und dem
gemüse dazu das haben wir an drei
stationen ja aus dem einfachen grund
weil wir sonst nicht nachkommt bei jeder
gast kann bei uns so viel hunger essen
wie er möchte
das ist schon einiges was manche leute
an hummer essen können
es
bleibt hier mehr leute bitte den humor
vor
noch drei minuten
[Musik]
in der royal promenade folgt die
ansprache des kapitäns
[Musik]
im namen der reederei der besatzung der
offiziere und mir willkommen an bord
schön dass sie bei uns sind
[Applaus]
die brotkörbe werden vorbereitet nun
braucht es jede hand tobias weis für
viele passagiere ist das kapitänsdinner
etwas ganz besonderes
festliche stimmung im speisesaal die
aargauer genießen den abend und lassen
sich verwöhnen
[Musik]
mit dem clapton das ganze mache ich
alles das wirkliche action sie
die ganz grob ermittelt anhand einer
können das war ganz ganz ganz arg
[Musik]
dann mit prothesen mediamarkt prozessor
ein vorweg potatoes template für tobias
und sein team beginnt jetzt die heiße
phase
gebt mir bitte an durchgebraten das
grillfleisch mit kartoffelstock
bleibt jetzt hier die kölner warten
schon es muss schneller gehen
tausende fest wings müssen innerhalb
weniger stunden serviert werden
[Musik]
in der arktis wasser so weit das auge
reicht das expeditionsschiff ist auf dem
weg nach grönland
um viertel nach zehn
möchte ich die deutschsprachigen gäste
einladen in speisesaal etwas über die
arktis befahren viel spaß und wir sehen
uns da
reiseleiter michael ist im stress schon
in wenigen minuten beginnt seinen
vortrag
in nassau auf den bahamas freuen sich
die passagiere der iju of the seas auf
ihren ersten landausflug
[Musik]
für den besuch auf der insel haben sich
freddy und guido passend eingekleidet
[Musik]
nicht nur die dimensionen des schiffes
lassen freddy und guido staunen auch die
forsche art der insulaner
franz
sie tauchen ein in eine fremde welt
schon kommt das nächste angebot wie wäre
es mit einer inselrundfahrt
margret feilscht um den preis
schließlich werden sie sich einig
12 dollar pro person aber nur für eine
stunde denn die zeit ist knapp und das
schiff wartet nicht
so
morgan und wie geht's alle gut
geschlafen alle ausreichend gefrühstückt
den gestrigen sensationellen tag schon
fast wieder vergessen km oder nein
gut kommen wir zu den hauptprotagonisten
und sprechen ein wenig über wale wale
haben seit jahrtausenden die menschen
bewegt wale sind säugetier sie als
vortragender ist michael in seinem
element eine anpassung an ihre lebens
war doch der arbeiter unterbrochen der
schwanz
ja wenn wahl vortrag herrscht dann kommt
plötzlich die wale hoch ich würde
vorschlagen
schnappt euch kameras geht raus genießt
die show das dürfte nicht verpassen
[Musik]
perfektes ende also das ist genau das
was man sich eigentlich wünscht sehr
spezielle free theorie und auch radio
und praktisch gerade
praxis an geschwungen und trennen sich
das normale ich find's super
perfekt so gut
war in der nächsten folge beobachten die
passagiere der plan cius die seltenen
säugetieren der welt und war mayr und
andré ihren wagen eine schlauchbootfahrt
im eis in der karibik feiert guido
geburtstag
und offizier nick gewährt einblicke ins
leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]